folks we have to now pray at the altar
of joe biden joe biden has now
reduced gas prices 22 days in a row
how did he do it obviously because joe
biden was to blame for higher gas prices
in every country
we must now praise joe biden for this
notable
extended decline to gas prices
i'm not actually being serious but let
me tell you what it is that is going on
and then we will talk about it gas
prices continue to drop
gas prices fell another two cents
yesterday to 477 per gallon according to
the latest aaa data down 24 cents from
the highest ever recorded level of five
dollars and one and a half cents last
month
gas prices are on track to continue
falling
though maybe not fast enough for
president joe biden who has criticized
gas stations for keeping prices uh
keeping prices high
so i tweeted
sort of tongue-in-cheek yesterday
gas prices have declined 21 days in a
row
how did joe biden do this
it was completely satirical
and with 50 000 likes on that tweet as
of this morning and maybe more at this
point in time
uh most people understood it
but not everybody and some people
thought i was being serious and actually
responded to me saying david joe biden's
irresponsible actions are responsible
for gas prices having gone up
but he didn't do anything to lower them
oh okay so when a democrat sees higher
gas prices it's their fault
but when a democrat sees declining gas
prices it has nothing to do with that
democrat i've got it now of course you
would probably be asking one of the same
questions i've been asking
how is joe biden responsible
for gas prices being up
in most countries over the last year
and how can we now say he has nothing to
do if that is his major responsibility
which is incredible one man responsible
for higher gas places globally now they
go down and we say it has nothing to do
with him that doesn't really make a lot
of sense when gas prices go down under a
democrat conservatives say nothing it's
only when they go up and remember when
prices were up under donald trump
conservatives said nothing they didn't
complain i wonder why that is so we can
look at some of the data here gas buddy
is a good website tracking this as you
can see there was this peak just under
502 per gallon right around uh what was
that mid-june i guess we would call it
um and now gas prices down
not a crazy amount down about five
percent now there's a couple of
different things that are going on
one of them is that the price of crude
oil
has started to decline relatively
significantly you might remember that
briefly in march crude oil prices hit
what was this 123 dollars per barrel
crude oil is the source material for
what is eventually refined into gasoline
that we
not me i'm on electric now but that
people
put in their put in their cars and
speaking of electric vehicles there's a
reason i bring that up
sustained high gas prices aren't
particularly good
for the oil industry you might think
well the higher the gas prices are the
more money they make
in the short and medium term maybe but
if the longer the the gas prices are
sustained at a high level the more
people will say when it comes time to
replace their vehicle i'm going to get
off gas altogether and go to an electric
vehicle
that's not good for the gas for the
gasoline industry so we had that spike
to about 123 dollars per barrel in march
and then we had another spike almost to
the same level 122 dollars per barrel
about a month ago and now as of
yesterday oil prices were all the way
down to what does this look like about
98.99
per barrel that's a pretty significant
decline
in a perfect world you would eventually
see that same proportional decline about
17 18 percent trickle down to gasoline
it almost never happens i'm reminded of
uh we've seen
those who have those of us who have
paid attention to or purchased airline
tickets over the last 15 20 years
remember that every time that um jet
fuel prices and crude oil prices go up
um airplane tickets go up and sometimes
there's fuel surcharges and all these
different things but then when the
prices of jet fuel come down and crude
oil come down those are rarely if ever
removed they're sort of like permanent
and um we often don't see gas prices gas
prices will mirror
the increases in oil prices but they
will not mirror the decreases but but
needless to say
i don't think joe biden really has
anything to do with this i didn't think
joe biden had anything to do with gas
prices going up and i think he has
essentially nothing to do with gas
prices going down he released a little
bit of oil from the strategic petroleum
reserve
very modest impact and that that's
really the tool other than you know
going to war with an oil-rich nation or
a gas tax holiday
um
releasing supply from the strategic
petroleum reserve is one of the very few
tools presidents have this stuff is
global this stuff is cyclical it tends
to move relatively slowly we're now it's
about three and a half weeks and it's
like a five percent decrease that we've
seen so
my expectation and i don't really make
predictions that i would ever suggest
anyone
make any financial decisions on my
expectation just based on what we've
been seeing we've seen a slowdown in the
growth to the inflation rate i expect to
see that continuing to come down gas
prices are going to be a part of that
and my my guess is and it's not a guess
i'm betting on remember this is my guess
but in terms of financial stuff i'm just
doing the same thing i always do just
every month
maintaining my asset allocation i'm not
making any shorts or investments in any
commodities i think over the next six
months we will see inflation taper off
we will see gas prices continue to come
down particularly as we are now we are
now at a time that gas prices are often
really expensive the the summer driving
season as it's often called and i think
six months from now things are going to
look a lot more uh more more reasonable
what we're now getting to and we talked
about this yesterday with pat on the
bonus show
is that first there were recession fears
because of such high prices and
inflation
now as we're seeing that start to taper
a little bit
there are recession fears
over a demand collapse so either way
you'll find people who have recession
fears i have no idea if we're heading
into a recession but at least the gas
price numbers are starting to come down
and i'm ready for all the right wingers
who blamed biden for gas prices being up
to praise him for them being down i'm
ready i'm not expecting it i'm not
holding my breath but i'm ready if they
want to be at least consistent let me
know your thoughts let me know what
you're seeing locally you can find me on
twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free
when you use the promo code pacman all
you have to do is pay five dollars
shipping